oh that burns
hi everybody this is jake from geek
culture and today we're looking at
something literally hot out the oven as
we'll be unboxing the far cry 6
collectors edition
[Music]
now here's the big boy right over here
the far cry 6 collectors edition now
looking at the design of the box as you
can see this is what we'll be putting
together later on the headlining tostado
flamethrower now we look at the rest of
the box here as you can see fire is a
rebellion alive and well
here's the tostado in all its flame in
glory and of course that symbol for the
libertad the rebellion movement against
anton castillo in yara
now before we really unbox this nice
collector's edition here's a word from
our fellow freedom fighters this video
is brought to you by secret lab here at
geek culture we love our circulators
especially the all-new 2022 titan evo
with its revamped 4-way lumbar system
for enhanced back support if pu leather
2.0 isn't your cup of tea then consider
the all-new soft weave even more soft
and breathable than before the chair
comes in more colours including this
lovely frost blue the tyson evo is even
magnetized along the hit pillow to stick
on the headrest of course there are even
more new features so do check them out
at secretlab.co
here we go unboxing the collector's
edition for far cry 6. now let's take a
look at the first layer over here we
already have some goodies let me just
bring it up for you guys to see here you
go we're going to take things out one by
one
so first of all we have this very nice
postcard from the team at ubisoft
southeast asia thank you guys for
providing us this collector's edition to
unbox from yara with love with an
alligator biting off my leg
perfect
then we have this very very nice
limited edition
far cry 6 steel book with some really
really awesome artwork
as well on the front and on the back we
have the libertad symbol again of course
with us going to this sunny island of
yara we have the map
uh this as you can see we're gonna open
it up
it's gonna look like a giant
island full of stuff for you to do
on this side we have some very nice art
of this island tropical island culture
here in yara and of course on the flip
side we have all the locations and
regions you'll be visiting in the game
as you try to free the island from anton
castillo so there's some nice stickers
here for the libertad and of course i
think an assortment of other symbols you
can find in yara
you also have this uh
very nice selected game soundtrack
we have a list of 17 tracks that you can
play and get into that rebellion mood
and then my favorite
uh
is this very very awesome very very
adorable chorizo charm
so if you didn't know chorizo is this
paraplegic puppy that can help you
distract your opponents and of course
bite their face off when when he feels
like it
he's one of the many amigos that you
will find in the game
of which i shall not spoil you should
have fun looking at the different amigos
and their abilities
and of course we also have this very
nice little gorilla art book
we can take a look i'm just going to
show you guys here a little bit
very very nice art
which you can
enjoy at your own time and last but not
least
it's very nice
i guess instructions menu on how to
example the tostado
you know the same way a gorilla would on
yara and there we have it the first
layer is done
now we move on into the tostado proper
and there we have it here's the big boy
the headliner the tostado flamethrower
now
unlike most other collectors edition
this baby actually needs some assembly
so you and i are gonna take this on a
journey today and put together this
pretty impressive looking flame thrower
so there we have it
two layers
of parts to put together like a true
gorilla
so as you can see from the instruction
there are total of seven parts
that hopefully i'll put together without
blowing myself to death
so let's start with the first one we
have this
nozzle
trick from i guess a petrol station in
yara
everything is good the trigger works
the material the rubber tubing looks
really really realistic
it might even be the real thing but
probably not it'll be too dangerous
we're gonna link this up
to this baby over here
some engine of some sort
you can see the detailing is really very
important looks like there's grease
marks over here
we have like a fuel gauge over here
so we can tell how much fewer you have
left in your tostado
so we're gonna just connect this
nozzle
i
believe into this area over here
just to be clear it doesn't really
how do i put it it doesn't really
connect to anything
just in case you thought you'd be
raising hell at your neighbor's door or
something we're going to add in
this
particular part again look at the
detailing
those rust marks on those metal
and of course that orange tip to tell
you that it's safe
so if you didn't already know
you know the the rebels don't really
have the best resources to work with so
in order to fight against the regime
they're trying to put together as much
weapons as they can from their everyday
items
so
we have that nozzle we have
oh this is a leaf blower engine
and then we're going to get this
i'm going to insert it right here
i really can't
it looks like they're grooves but it
really i cannot this is why i get
collector's editions that are already
assembled did he do it
there we go perfect there you have it
and this is why i'm not cut out to be a
rebel but he is
far cry 6.
this looks really really awesome already
but of course we're not done yet
we don't have that fuel canister
now look at this
it just spells danger and in any game
you see something red you shoot it it
blows up so
you know what happens
uh we need number five as well
which is this
i guess this holder for the canister
locked into place
now i'm going to figure out how to put
this in
this
way me figure it out how are we going to
get this in
[Applause]
i'm so afraid of it breaking
there you go
perfect
secured
there you go canister no
now move on to number six
which is another nozzle
hmm
again
great trigger action over there
we're gonna attach this to
oh my god
where is it is this place
i think so
perfect
connect this nozzle here i think
there we go
and then lastly we're gonna add
the fire starter
which is here
this is taken from apparently a fire
starter that lights up candles at a
birthday party
we're gonna put this right here and
screw that into place
there we go i think we're good
this thing is gonna go in i'm going to
try to squeeze this in
oh those sounds
those sounds of their plastic but there
you have it
it completely examined tostado with some
difficulty i would say but
the ample rock looks so good so
this starts the fire at the fire starter
here
and then you're gonna fire off using
this
nozzle here for the fuel
sally non-working tostado
but you know this is to look great as a
display piece in any collection
now
to display it
let's get this stand out
look at that far cry 6. logo here
there's a plastic film which i will not
remove
i assume it's like this
this makes sense
does this make
sense there you have it
everyone tostado
[Music]
and there you have it the full
collector's edition for far cry 6 with
all these goodies and of course this
flaming hot tostado now if you want to
get this for your collection you better
start pre-ordering now because these
things are going to run out fast and
speaking of collectibles here's one more
you can add to your growing collection
which is the master assassin at zeo from
the ubisoft animus collection as you can
see the detailing on this figure that
digitalization of the animus as well as
those hidden blades so if you're a big
fan of ezio like myself this piece will
definitely have a home in your
collection so you can be a happy
assassin or templar and that about wraps
up this video
until then my name is jake i'm from geek
culture and we'll see you at the next
one
[Music]
you